i'm quite stubborn yeah you guys are
you're both very
you're right you're fiery salty we have
the similarities
i really am america's ass i mean if you
think about it
yeah there's some there's some there's
some vibes i have to watch out for all
the time
tries to trip me a lot um into giving me
hugs
we have unfinished business
we have to go back to where it all
started
i'm gonna say it for everybody that's
been thinking it and wishing for it it's
about
time that you get your own movie it's
about time
yeah i guess it's about time
i'll be there whenever she says that
let me go it's funny because i've had a
lot of
kind of mixed reactions of you know her
ultimate fate and end game
but for me it made so much sense that
she would
sacrifice herself not just for the
greater good of humanity but
but actually for her friends which was
really at the heart of it
and um you know yeah she's she's a good
one
mia renner mia renner sophie's choice
so let's set it up where we are in the
the marvel universe with this movie
because it's not a prequel it's like
kind of a mid
equal i mean that's a different that's a
different movement that's happening soon
exactly
um it is a uh let's see how can i
marvelize this for you
it is um you'll get good at this too
um so much
this is obviously pre-infinity war and
post-civil war okay there
so you were already mad at that answer
[Music]
i used to have nothing
and then i got this
this job
this family i think what's interesting
is to place it at this time
you already know the mythology of what
she's gonna do in those movies
and so how she got to that place a
couple years before
by reuniting with these people from her
past
still fits there's this guy called the
red guardian
he was groomed by the soviet union to be
the counterpart to captain america
during the cold war
they developed super soldiers and uh you
know the red guardian was
the soviet union's answer to captain
america
mason my character is kind of like a
fixer i i can get anybody anything they
need i got the helicopter for example
oh that's your work i can hook you up
yeah yeah exactly this is my work
okay so um so natasha uses me a lot to
get anything from a safe house to
equipment to anything but we've kind of
got a little bit of a history
you say a little bit of a free song you
know romantic undertones if you will
and so um don't do that face you look
rather like assistant ooh ot's got a
girlfriend
and there's some there's some vibes you
know there's some vibes but it's it's
tough you know when the person you're
into is a
international assassin you know i mean
it just makes makes relationships
no then you it keeps you in line one
wrong move
right she starts reaching for the draw
you're like whoa whoa whoa i'm sorry
about it
i'm sorry baby i'm sorry let's talk
about her like she's not here
okay okay what makes florence like
somebody we really need to watch out for
like the one toy i have to watch out for
all the time
she tries to trip me a lot um into
giving me hugs
snuggly these are all snuggly
i i mean it's so embarrassing to talk
about somebody when they're right i can
turn around but um
[Laughter]
florence is such a talented actor and
she's the real deal
she's she's an amazing scene partner and
she's you know she she just has a fresh
take on everything
is just there meets you right there it's
awesome
i i love working with her the energy i
already i dig the energy between so we
haven't seen each other in a week so a
lot of love yeah i miss this one
let's talk about this counterpart to
captain america yeah let's talk about
the david harper and
versus chris come on my waistline is a
lot larger
so when i say things are bigger in this
movie i primarily mean my waistline you
are something
yeah no because somebody talked about
america's ass with me
and i think i didn't want to go there
but i think that it is i mean it's what
it's a big part of the movies right
that is america's ass you know he is the
ass that is the ideal but
i really am america's ass i mean if you
think about it
how are you most like natasha um oh gosh
i um i think natasha's really good at
compartmentalizing
and it's it's both good and bad people
wear this the exact same clothes
yes every day every day where the thing
is these walking boots
every day it's really hard to get around
a great choice i'm like scarlet give me
the shoe
are you most like elena in real life
hairstyle almost
hairstyle mostly i love the two
ponytails
uh no i i i i don't know
did she eat a lot i think personally if
i would like i could answer
that question for you i'm quite stubborn
yeah you guys are you're both very
you're right you're fiery salty we have
the similar salty
[Music]
you're welcome that's probably one of
the coolest things about our
relationship
is it's so much like well a best friends
family
women it's like fighting and hate and
anger but
love and they come back together all the
time and that's it's pretty cool
to have these strong women uh basically
fight everything together when you walk
on this set how does it compare to like
every other set that you smashes them
all to the ground
no i mean it's it's it's great i mean in
particular you know i just
love working with talented people and so
kate our director is just she's
extraordinary
yeah they're all the toys and the guns
and you know copped up but
uh yeah it's working with great lovely
people we have an incredible crew but we
have an amazing group of women
who are just coming to work every day
and just committed to making this
something that's real and deep and
visceral
there's a lot more security a lot of
people don't want you to leave your
sides around
it just feels big like the big action
sequences are enormous
when it really sunk in it was at comic
con three weeks ago or something and we
walked out and i it was
like that's when i was like okay it's
happened
it's happening
yeah i managed to get my nephew to be an
extra on one of the days and so
you really are kind of methodism going
on
the training is it the same no it's way
harder because i'm older now
so everything is more painful i mean i
think i'm in
i'm in pretty good shape uh she's a
great show
playing this role for as long as you
have like keeps you you gotta kick butt
a lot
so it keeps you yeah i i am that's right
i get i actually get paid to go mostly
to the gym it's so fun though amazing
they're so fun then you get to do it on
set with scarlet and you're like what is
my life
that's pretty cool when you see my
rickety old body and you're like oh no i
don't want that
no yeah at some point we all have to
choose
[Music]
between what the world wants you to be
and who you are
how proud does it make you though to
know not only i know you're teaching
your daughter lots of good stuff but to
know you're leaving like this legacy for
her to
see of this woman you know forever
that feels like something that will be
challenging to me and something that
i've i've never done before and i think
that is something that i'm actually
more um excited to show her if you know
you can
do something but you don't know quite
how you're going to do it you know
taking that kind of risk and the reward
that
that's possible um is is really worth it
[Music]